elle même a dit qu'en 2017 quand elle
avait vu le visage des manuels macron
s'afficher sur les écrans elle avait eu
envie de pleurer et qu'elle était comme
pétrifié qu'elle n'arrivait pas à se
projeter dans ce cas là ça sert à quoi
une première dame en vrai pardon pour la
culture un peu brut ben moi depuis les
pierres chaudes et j'avais su les modes
veille par par chaque parent chaque
première dame d'ailleurs c'est simple
manuel macron avait voulu faire il avait
voulu institutionnaliser le statut de la
première dame ouais ça avait soulevé les
foudres de beaucoup de ses détracteurs
voilà qui n'avaient pas pu le faire
finalement du coup chacune dessine un
peu son rôle ça va de carla bruni qui a
accompagné en gros son mari aux voyages
à l'étranger à l'egypte a conquis à
essayer d'être plus impliqué à l'option
elle fait comme moi pardon je laime
beaucoup je pousse une femme formidable
en cinq ans j'ai pas berner de t-rex et
les pièces jaunes pas j'en ai associés
mais j'ai même l'impression que si tu
m'as croco tombés pendant la campagne
quand on lui pose une question elles
baissent un peu la tête elle répond de
manière très très courte pour dire j'ai
pas dire une connerie on fait la queue
matras en reprise qu'est ce qu'elle a
fait pendant pendant cinq ans c'était
quoi son rôle elle a rencontré beaucoup
de gens pour son mari comme elle le fait
d'ailleurs depuis toujours c'est-à-dire
depuis 2014 quand emmanuel macron est
devenu ministre de l'économie est là
elle elle était toujours à ses côtés
c'était un peu son éminence grise c'est
celle qui pousse des fiches qui
rencontrait d'allégeance et riche et
tout ça plein de ses fils elle les
faisait tous tout mais au moment de la
campagne elle a rencontré beaucoup des
futurs ministres par exemple jean michel
blanquer elle est très proche de marlène
schiappa et
oui ça fait beaucoup appris beaucoup et
oui oui pourquoi tu demandes ce qu'elle
est ce qu'elle fait elle fait plein de
choses mais en coulisses avec emmanuel
macron elle le conseille beaucoup
notamment à chaque remaniement elle a
insisté sur les noms elle s'en est
jamais caché mes dons qui comptait pour
elle comme marlène schiappa mais aussi
bruno le maire parce qu'elles étaient
très proches de la maman de bruno le
maire dont calais voilà la raison pour
ma terminé ses moyens et ses sages où
elle a connu bien avant ça joue donc
voila l avis au président croyable sur
chaque remaniement c'est pareil il ya de
pardon flyers les deux premières dames
qu'on jouait ce rôle là un peu de
conseillère plus qu culte c'est
évidemment obligé le patron et c'est
cécilia sarkozy c'est les deux qui ont
vraiment fait un binôme avec leurs mecs
si j'ose dire pour faire gagner un côté
quai dédié un côté voilà c'est un couple
qui descendent quand on est président on
a la tête dans le guidon on a tellement
de boulot et c'est la femme qui elle a
un emploi du temps moins chargé ça lui
permet de rester un peu les pieds sur
terre elle reçoit le courrier l'elysée
des gens qui écrivent à emmanuel macron
qui n'a pas le temps évidemment de
louvres et son prix est liée à lui fait
un retour un peu de l'opinion publique
mais en raison des risques se cacher on
est président on entouré que de
flatteurs que tu soeur donc il faut
quelqu'un qui dise le courrier
responsable j'ai pas dit que c'est à la
mode qui l'aura de savoir c'est rentrer
à tout petit peu maintenant dans l'est
dans l'intimité de l'elysée
est-ce que c'est au dernier étage est ce
qu'ils dorment dans l'une des dents une
dans la même chambre et ce qu'ils ont
une petite cuisine à côté pour eux
seulement parce que c'est de le faire
une tablette le soir c'est pas besoin
que sa perte au moins un club des tarifs
froides à 4 heures du matin c'est quoi
le petit quotidien à l'ouest qui vivent
leur quotidien ils se situent dans les
appartements privés qui pourraient être
à 100 mètres carrés comme alors oui le
palais de l'elysée c'est pas c'est pas
un palace en fait on imagine c'est quand
même un truc merveilleux mais non il ya
des problème de rongeurs il ya beaucoup
de souris ont fait allez vous voulez y a
des poils end en kilt règles lois
françaises
en revanche ils ont quand même de beaux
appartements et ils ont fait certaines
rénovations notamment au niveau du décor
elle avait fait enlever beaucoup de
tentures beaucoup de trucs qu'il ya
lourd dit c'est un peu l'ambiance après
les journées types elle elle se lève
très tôt parce qu'elle fait beaucoup de
sport le matin à l'aube ouais une heure
et demie de vélo d'appartement elle
prend ensuite son petit déj avec avec
emmanuel macron ça c'est leur petit
rituel immuable le soir aussi ils dînent
ensemble à plus de 12 ans en ski
emmanuel maquet regarde la télé
- dans quel cadre
imoca c'est regarder si rim qui
regardent terrible je ne suis pas aimé
que jamais eu si les premières dames
elles ont elles n'ont pas de statut
officiel non non non non pas de sa
cheville c'est dire qu'en fin de compte
elles sont sous pratiquement
ouais attention vous laisser pas mal
taper sur les sous non non il ya aucun
dérapage excuse moi mathieu et aucun
dérapage non mais elles sont elles sont
aux frais de l'état bien sûr elle est
rentré les nacelles à dire qu'elles
n'ont pas de statut officiel sera un
budget en fin de compte elles sont là on
s'est pas tu as fait alors ses notes un
peu dur quand même
non mais c'est très transparent c'est à
dire quel est l'enjeu 440 mille euros
ouais qui n'est pas énorme carence en
avant ses parents et non mais attendez
qu'ils s'envoient mais c'est une
orientation bien sûr mais par rapport
aux autres première dame bernadette
chirac avait 23 collaborateurs oui c'est
ma 4e faire quoi et pour faire la
différence et xue les hôpitaux de paris
pour s'occuper du bien c'est de faire
ses déplacements pour sa sécurité elle
faisons pas les naïfs l'on n'en fait pas
des naïfs en effet de comprendre on
essaie de comprendre
début d'une idée de ce que fait une
première dame prochaine de l'état ont
été protégés déjà guère entend le
terrorisme 24/24 taipei d un vrai rôle
parfois dramatiques
s'était dit lord et j'avais peur des
gens il ya tout un boulot ont fait
d'après mr dame américaine voit le first
lady ça vient évidemment aux états unis
sans avoir le statut officiel et à kof
les first lady américaine l.gallois
donc on sait exactement ce qui se passe
combien gagne combien les ans elles sont
dans east wing monsieur et danguel swing
l aléa is win sauf que là il n'y a pas
de statut légal il ya même une première
dame qui avait refusé qu'on l'appelle
première dame s'était danielle
mitterrand dit ne m'appelez jamais
première dame moi je suis au tout début
de la troisième
en plus c'est pas juste accueilli sans
doute la première dame peut-être la
police charismatique elle a échappé à
une tentative d'attentât rouiba l'été en
irak au grand soutien des kurdes elle
était hyper engagé à gênés quand même
mitterrand parce que la france avait des
relations avec la chine est la rencontre
le dalaï lama presque d'entre eux son
mari qu'elle avait vraiment un rôle
politique n'est même pas conseillé a été
beaucoup plus sélectionné pour tout un
peuple et être un peu crapuleux qui
parraine il paraît qu'elle lui fait bri
macron lui fait une tutelle est le soir
lui fait la cuisine ça c'est vrai ou pas
tous les soirs oui votre tous les soeurs
n'ont peut-être pas un champion les
cuisines de l'elysée elle les a vérifiés
dans le sens de menus très light elle
était allée voir guillaume gomez qui
était le chef de l'état à l'époque à son
arrivée en disant nous ce sera dix
fruits et légumes par jour dit fatigué
par ces mots je dis ça marche qu'il est
il est bien ce qu on fait des matches où
on aime on n'a pas de président mais les
magnifiques et et à vendre le souhaitent
à venir c'est une petite anecdote a pu
quand même y paraît il paraît que
quelques jours après leur arrivée au
palais et ils ont fait un petit câlin et
sans s'en rendre compte ils ont
déclenché un interrupteur d'urgence
ses toiles avec donald jean ba oui
comment en fait la leçon est censé n'en
méritait pas dans la
veut que l'argent montait voit le
président en personne ouais de ses
propres yeux sauf que brigitte a dit
dans l'entrebâillement de la pharmacie
emmanuel maquet nom n'est pas visible à
d'imaginer qu'une baignoire c'est une
erreur c'est une
[Applaudissements]
alors isabelle que cali question depuis
20 ans cet argent pas lancement qui nous
écoutent et derrière
hypatie falaise il ya
[Rires]
un hic c'est que quand emmanuel macron
on est en pleine campagne est venu à rtl
quand elle est sortie avec le marché de
nuit il est allé acheter un bouquet de
fleurs à brigitte et il l'a payé de ses
propres deniers ce qui n'est pas
spectaculaire en soit
merci
prend la parole pour dire à sa femme des
fleurs s'épanouissent et d'errance amy
mais oui sinon c'est si pour les 18 ans
sur la cafetière sera vase ou bien c'est
très conscient je suis sûr que vous le
saviez pas c'est mal votre prénom c'est
moyen mais est-ce que vous avez déjà été
à l'elysée vous non non donc vous
pourrit pas parce que non mais l'élysée
faut savoir qu'avant c'était une maison
close est ce que vous le saviez ça oui
mais voila voila
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci mon char une ancienne maison close
et je vous laisse à bien vous y aviez t
le lion de prêt à porter des robes et
pour qu'ils aillent faire des trucs un
peu ça non c'est toi je vous assure
qu'on
planté g gir 6 days inn et maisons
closes merci sa vie on s'était c'est
tellement gros scoop de la soirée ça
doit pas visite m'a conquis un humour
assez potache en fait d'un oui c'est
valérie moret c'est vrai j'y allais elle
est assez gouailleuse en fait elle adore
par exemple l'émission les grandes
gueules
mais surtout est-ce qu'on peut aussi
mettre un petit peu les pieds dans le
plat aussi usé de mots mais c'est aussi
là c'est la première fois votre
guillemets qu'on a un président fidèle
oui parce que je vis des nouvelles
pardon c'est vrai j'ai parlé après la
présidentielle bat qui s'est pas fait
piquer en tout cas
alors on ne
vais défendre les femmes
de supporter la plupart des chefs d'état
qui ont été des
atouts va donc de supporter cette
pression là d'être une femme marion chef
d'état mais soeur et de deux de
supporter ça moi je vais courage aux
femmes courageux enfin moi alors
il fait applaudir les fêtes de chantier
il peut il fait tout oui oui une petite
anecdote pour rebondir sur ce que dit
laurent et pour rendre hommage à
bernadette chirac oui tu m'étonnes sem
après lui rendre hommage parce que j'ai
eus claude chirac et quelques semaines
au téléphone pour un projet et on a
discuté un petit peu de ses parents et
elle m'a dit il faut pas croire
bernadette c'était la plus drôle du
couple mais oui c'était celle qui
faisait les blagues tout le temps oui
qui faisait rire à table qui pouvait
même dé faire des blagues à se laisser
aller à des blagues un peu olé olé voir
un peu graveleuses et c'était vraiment
le pitre du couple voilà donc foulé les
gens étaient passées à l'elysée disait
que c'était aussi la tenue la plus
odieux de la voile
très drôle et à tirana ont porté un soin
tillous voilà je viens c'est une femme
qui m'a énormément fait rire je lis
beaucoup suivi pendant le tournage d'un
documentaire avec agnès vincent qui
était la patronne des opérations
spéciales à ce moment là sur le service
public et bernadette massé mourir de
rire et compris une fois quand elle m'a
montré comment vous une phase heures sur
le sol et y remettre la tête entre les
gens à vous faire prendre des coups et
elle était mais vraiment à mourir
[Musique]
bah
c'est quoi une patte il ya
l'effet est
saisissant
moi j'avais fait une émission qui
s'appelait 10h le mag sur tf1 à vous en
souvenez pas parce qu'elle a duré qu'un
an comme ça n'a pas marché
pourquoi eh ben elle était assise à côté
de moi et le marais à voter un jour que
dans la rue on arrêtait souvent parce
qu'en fait les gardes du corps se marche
un peu loin derrière donc les gens se
rendent pas compte que des gardes du
corps elle marchait seule dans la rue
les gens n'arrêtaient disant vous êtes
bernadette chirac elle répondait non pas
du tout certainement pas élevé ça
m'emmerde de parler aux gens je dis
certainement pas pour ne pas leur
répondre voilà des pédagogues qui
venaient les hôtes de d'isabelle
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir monsieur soit essayer de bien
appuyer beaucoup de monde ici veut dire
que c'est aussi pas un rôle facile parce
que on se souvient tous des rumeurs
abjectes et odieuse qui ont été dix
contre onze pendant contre brigitte
macron je ne le répéterai pas parce que
c'est vraiment honteux est ce que l on a
souffert sincèrement parce que du coup
on s'est posé la question est ce qu'il
ya vraiment du désert quoi et à tel
point que alors si vous parlez des
rumeurs sur la section oui oui j'ai même
pas envie non
c'est le stade dernière l'appui la
dernière chez lapierre a expliqué là
pour les gens quand même la dernière
minute à la rumeur disait que c'était un
homme et quatre sièges j'ai pas envie
d'alimenter c'est pour ça que je vais
pas le dire la td donc c'est
effectivement c'est odieux mais voilà
ils soient pas toujours quelle part de
par son histoire avec emmanuel macron
parce que quand ils se sont mis ensemble
évidemment ils ont subi les foudres de
toute leur famille les quolibets de
tourner enfin une petite ville de
province dans lesquels dans laquelle il
était montrée du doigt dans quel est le
dit qu'elle s'est endurci n'empêche que
pendant la campagne de 2010 est que ce
soit toutes les rumeurs sur emmanuel
macron toutes les blagues sur elle et
les insultes hurel qui était quand même
hyper violente et c'est bien balancé sur
portes le temps que je vous rappelle que
c'est le premier aussi qui la première
année de son élection a dit à table un
jour devant tout le monde je vous
rappelle aussi et je n'ai rien contre ça
que je ne suis pas homosexuel
a que des voix la campagne électorale et
personne ne s'attendait à ce qu'il dit
ça et il a parlé devant des militants
disant si vous entendez parler de mes
soirées ce genre une douce sexuels avec
des hommes etc voilà je vous dis non
j'ai pas le temps il ne s'est pas tort
le premier a balancé sur la rumeur
éviter de pour la casse est roi
quelque part il en parler parce qu'ils
savaient que ça me laissait aussi
président d'un clan qui voulaient tordre
le cou à la cua très bien et pour parler
des maîtresses aussi pardon parler des
habitudes et tout ça mais pour parler
des maîtresses je pense que ce le
président que le plus maîtresse c'est
sans doute pour les a pas comptés mais
est jacques chirac
et mitterrand et la petite histoire veut
que la morgue le sort de la mort de lady
di la maison 97 elmer et tout le monde
essaie de le joindre et personne ne sait
où il est parce qu il était avec une
actrice espagnole c'est ça dans une
chambre un lapin en espagnol ou italien
l'italienne plus tôt elles viennent
pardon c'est ça j'ai pas cité le nom
s'est passé l'élégante en quantité non
ça c'est qui bah c'est une très grande
actrice italienne a fait l'auteur
d'un cardinal kung salut tu sais mais
les italiennes par des bagnoles bernard
l'a compris à ses très rapidement en
fait à qui elles avaient affaire oui et
donc il n'y avait pas déjà entre 74 et
76 il était sorti avec une journaliste
du figaro il était question d'un divorce
et c'est à ce moment là en fait que le
couple a basculé dans autre chose et où
bernadette a dit on est un couple
d'ambition on a un couple d'ambition un
peu à la clinton il faut savoir que l on
parlait tout à l'heure de secrétaire
mais elle a commencé en apprenant en
faisant des cours de dactylo pour lui
faire réviser les n'a donc c'est à dire
que dès le départ à la haye la préfet
comme à cesser cet effet pour directrice
et puis je rappelle qu elle aussi avait
visiblement pas arrêter l'histoire avec
son prof de sport de corrèze était c'est
carla bruni t'aime pardon thiam ainsi
valéry giscard d'estaing mais je n'ai
pas remonter trop loin
si l'on remonte aussi à claude pompidou
et ne quittera pas les viviers là on a
le palais vivienne qui étiez sur le tour
dont alors pour le coup mon oncle était
au ministère des affaires étrangères à
ce moment là il ya une nuit où valéry
giscard d'estaing inter ligues majeures
et ils ont eu besoin de le joindre pour
une urgence et il était introuvable dont
l'art est posée avec le joker du deuil
vrai problème est précieux
tu as une activité
président direct avec attention ce que
ses boucles d'oreilles en bougie qui
sont en rang devant
lui à détourner le descendeur l
assemblée jamais officié à la bruni
alors carla bruni quand même elle dit
qu'elle a très très mal vécu son passage
à l'elysée quand elle est sortie de
salle a fait une dépression dit qu'elle
ne l'avait jamais son linge par exemple
salle à l'elysée parce que le personnage
de les zèbres avait autre chose à faire
passer c'est vrai tout ça elle est un
peu gonflé parce qu'elle ne vivait pas
quand même à l'elysée elle lui donc elle
n'est pas très juste on installe
une fois la même fait le mur pour partir
rejoindre une collaboratrice elle a dû
se barrer en pyjama en faisant le mur
pour se barrer en toute discrétion oui
et par action permet de voir en pige et
c'est vrai savais pas que c'était là de
la première dame préféré du personnel de
l'elysée depuis oui parce qu'elle
n'était pas du tout exigeante en fait
elle ne se mêler de rien elle est déjà
là comme comme beaucoup avant elle quoi
cécilia non plus et puis ensuite valérie
trierweiler monde sont pas seuls a été
bref julie gayet et celle qui a été le
moins aimé et finalement c'est là
qu'elle
mérite
chirat
moi j'ai un nom qui m'est venue il parle
c'est les plus odieuses mais je préfère
c'est sûr que tu le dis toi bah oui les
gentils mais jamais non pas bernadette
données vivantes dans les sillons
avait dit de toi parce que des gens par
temps nuageux le dire et solaire non non
valérie du chien du goût du président
vient pas du chat la première dame et
première
sous un tunnel je n'entends rien mais
adam qui a été jugée la plus odieuse
mathieu la plus odieuse et à les assumer
sait on peut le dire
personne moi je ne dirais pas parce qu
elle est très sympathique
l'erythrée alors absolument c'est un
véritable scoop